yeah that was one thing definitely when
i was designing my office where i
realized i thought i had a lot of stuff
but then i realized that a lot of it was
stuff that was on my wall that were
things like posters and wall scrolls
that i was like you know what
maybe it's time to change it up so yeah
so then i got really picky with what i
would put on the walls right so now i've
got like you know my gingivito bag i've
got the [ __ ] who skateboards i've got
the you know my youtube play button and
stuff like that you know stuff that is
more limited and like extravagant
yeah and then i realized oh i actually
don't have a lot of stuff that is
actually of value right right and uh
yeah and then i went on this like crack
binge of buying expensive [ __ ] now uh
now i have the reverse problem where i
have too much stuff now so
your room is just like the weeb haven
you know my my room is i i've somehow i
don't know how when it happened but i
i've turned into like a snobby art
collector when it comes to life
i think i'm going through that stage
yeah well i haven't got there yet i'm
just like jojo just give me jojo's like
every time i go to an exhibit now i'm
just like so where are the expensive
paintings
the [ __ ]
[ __ ] the mugs
[ __ ] the t-shirts [ __ ] the mugs i don't
i don't i don't want your [ __ ]
figures anymore don't want the posters
don't want the [ __ ] wall scrolls no i
don't want any [ __ ] give me the
paintings give me the cool shirt where's
the limited ship yeah exactly right what
can i frame yeah what can i what can i
display the glass box
we're gonna do the anime figure special
at some point you guys are saying this
[ __ ] what the [ __ ]
i love figures still yeah jojo no i'll
i'll you know i'll walk into like a
figurine shop and i'll be like so
were there more than a hundred of these
made i don't want it wow give it a
little [ __ ] because your privilege is
showing joe does this come with a
certificate of
because the authenticity has gone to
this man's head but the thing about
figures is that you just need a [ __ ] ton
of it before it looks any good otherwise
it just it's it just looks a little bit
tacky because it just it's it's too
small to be a centerpiece
but it needs to occupy like some space
right and it just it just looks
i don't know it unless you have like a
really really massive figure it does to
me it doesn't like it's but even then
like a really really big figure can
still look a little tacky depending on
where it is that's why i've like because
of because i have that like massive
berserk figure oh yeah you do and i'm
still to this day trying to figure out
where to put it because it's like
everywhere i've like envisioned it
putting it in my room yeah it just
doesn't look right for some reason and i
realize it might be because i need to
have it
next to a bunch of other figures yeah
but the problem is my figure shelf is
like tucked away in a cool container so
i can't put it in yes i'm like well [ __ ]
i have to like put this like [ __ ] in the
living room or something like coffee
table coffee table yeah
yeah
is this like that [ __ ] what what's
that word that's used to describe how
the energy of a room is dictated by
feng shui yeah yeah i'm trying to figure
out the feng shui of my giant bazaar
yeah
like as a kid i'm just like this is
stupid that they're like you could just
put things and it doesn't matter now
i've realized well my mood is affected
by how my room looks and i'm just like
why is this something i wouldn't go that
far personally for me i'm like yeah feng
shui though does get pretty ridiculous
at times yeah yeah it's like it's like
you'll get bad luck if the building is
done some of that is ridiculous but i
don't know even like my bedroom because
like i sleep better now because our
bedroom is orientated differently from
my old bedroom and i just realized oh
it's just because of where it is in
relation to where the window is and i'm
just like
when was it it wasn't before huh wasn't
no not near a window last time no it
wasn't it was like on the opposite side
of the window because i because that's
yeah i mean that yeah that probably
wouldn't i mean generally i think seeing
like outsiders
you make your brain happy yeah
normally your brain like that everything
like that
for me like because back back then i was
just like where can the bed take up the
most efficient amount of space
right in that corner right away from the
window yeah
you have room to put it in the middle
you put it in the middle right but then
that's like that's like a big brain
saying like i have space yeah yeah
exactly that's a flex
the other side of the beds i don't even
need them
nothing needs to go there i'm gonna put
the bed in the middle yeah yeah yeah i
know it's weird this is the first time
i've actually like try to think about
this rather than just like going forward
men discovers interior design yeah man
discovers materials i was like oh man i
got more space on my wall guess i'll buy
more jojo prince yeah right
i'll buy double so now i have double the
jojo prince on my wall
but i've got like a nice really cool
wall of jojo it's really nice yeah
whatever you done with like the rest of
your
merch that you built up at your place oh
there's a jojo yeah it's all on one like
four-shelf rack all right i managed to
place it and then i put like the
anti-earthquake things and the figures
that uh would fall over oh so yeah
that's uh i managed to somehow get it
all in but then i've got a bunch of
other stuff in other cupboards that i
can't like display like i have like
uh a really big wooden oak box
filled with the jojo ties
separate and like neat and presentable
but there's nowhere to put it because
like yeah i don't know i can't put on
the floor it's the jojo tires you can't
go on the floor you're insane
lose its value exactly i own fourteen or
fifteen something jojo
literally every jojo thai that's evident
there's like 24 oh really and uh i have
all of the ones from part four which is
12 ties in total holy [ __ ] i think it's
12.
so there's 12 ties from part four and i
think there's like eight or something
from par five right i didn't buy all of
them from part five so you know like
when you're a kid when you'd see that
documentary about that guy or girl who
would collect like barbie doll and ken
dolls you become that just with jojo man
i have not don't you dare good no
because
fast forward to like 50 years they would
go around they would dress up like ken
and be like i'm ken and they'd be like
please call you literally you're getting
everywhere you go you're a [ __ ] joker
oh come on that's dude it's like the
only piece of dress this is the meme
where it's like we are not the same you
wear ken outfit i wear jojo's suit we
are not the same
god wipes his ass i i pressure wash my
ass we are not the same gun don't
compare right don't compare me to those
[ __ ] people who cosplay we are not
the same i wear drip they wear outfits
it's not the same